so how did the system know that the Maps
app could handle this intent the
activity within the Maps app included an
intent filter like this one within its
manifest entry it indicates that the
Maps app is capable of performing this
view action on all data which has a geo
scheme you can use intent filters for
your activities to define the actions
they're capable of performing and
optionally the kind of data that they
can perform it on so when you use an
implicit intent to address a request to
start an activity much like you did with
Catherine and the open weather map org
link Android resolves this request by
checking the intent filters of every
activity that's installed on the device
until it finds the best possible match
if multiple activities match as in the
case with the web URL the user is given
a choice